it is going to last a while he yes he's
going to be coping with it for some time
so the curse has not been lifted the
spell has it's not a curse it's a spell
I mean let's get our jargon right now
amateur so the spell is definitely
having a very profound impact on him
it's maybe even akin it's it's I think
more pronounced even than the Mark of
Cain was for Dean it's very yes he's not
himself to say the least
yeah so in a sense I think that it
really was from stories like Angel
bedtime stories told two thousand years
ago where angels didn't even really
think the darkness was a real thing but
it was just a scary thing that that we
told it's karim if it's pre-biblical
which is an interesting concept going
back to sort of i don't know if this is
what they're going for but it could be
kind of like you know pre-big bang
concept like something really really
really ancient and very powerful and
very ominous it's going to provide a
very focused concrete fo for all the
boys this year I don't know what the
whole season art looks like but I can
tell you that at the beginning at the
outset he is once again quite alienated
from angels because of his breaking out
Metatron or taking medicine and letting
him escape and he's they don't they're
angry with him so I think that he is
going to be more the boys side and
working side by side with them than with
dealing with the politics of heaven to
go off supernatural Iquitos live about
the new challenges are going for dish
where's this year um sure so my
scavenger hunt dish was is coming up
right around the corner registration is
closing like in a week and we have been
talking to I can't really tell you
because I don't want to spoil anything
but we've been talking to some very
interesting people including some people
I will tell you at NASA who are going to
help come up with some items for the
scavenger hunt so yes and there's
another there's another thing in the
hopper that I can't talk about yet but
it will be very cool for the scavenger
hunt this year it is every year I try to
make it bigger and better and weirder
than it was the year before and so far
it looks like we're on track to meet
that
oh we've we've now I think we've broken
eight guinness world records with it and
we're going to try to do more you know
what can you do about that kind of thing
so yeah anybody wants to sign up we have
a lot of like supernatural related stuff
in the hunt and tons of supernatural
fans participate and then lots of people
outside of the supernatural fandom as
well
you